the morning job let's talk about the
Hunger Games a story about action and
love and a really really screwed up
society there's some easy things to
relate to here most of us can relate to
love a lot of people enjoy a good action
sequence and yeah we like to see the
underdog rising up against the evil
oppressive regime unimaginably
inequitable society in which people
starve while other people gorge
themselves so much that they have to
though then go puke so that they can eat
more the world where a table is worth
more than a human life that's like the
hardest thing to relate to out of the
whole movie except that it's not cuz we
kind of live in that world Suzanne
Collins does an amazing job of this of
showing us basically a world that looks
a lot like the world that we live in and
having us look at it and say how could
anyone live in a world like that she
also does a really admirable job of not
blaming the participants of that society
of Katniss and Effie are friends they
love each other
sadness is her friend despite the fact
that Effie has always been and continues
to be a participant in that culture of
oppression why is that well it's because
Effie isn't evil there's one thing that
exists in abundance in The Hunger Games
though that does not exist so much in
our world as nice as it would be if this
weren't true and as impossible as it
kind of is to believe our deeply in
equal society is not the result of a
bunch of bad guys we don't have a
President Snow or or we do have a
President Snow but he's not a person the
thing that causes inequality isn't some
corrupt politician it's not a bunch of
psychopathic CEOs the quality is caused
by human nature psychology sociology and
math it's calmed by math and you can't
fight math it's math let's take an
example two people one of them is rich
one of them is middle class they both
want to invest in Netflix a year ago a
middle-class person invest $10,000 the
rich person invests a million dollars
both of their money doubles in the next
twelve months that's a tremendous
success for both of them except that the
rich person has a million new dollars
and the middle-class person has 10,000
new dollars inequality is also created
by greed yes and it's created by
societal structures like rich people
helping out rich people makes rich
people much richer than poor people
helping up poor people and rich people
hang out with rich people and poor
people hang out with poor people that's
a problem it is not an easy problem to
solve
I love
discuss all of the different cultural
and psychological and sociological and
mathematical reasons for inequality
perpetuating itself and I'm not making a
documentary film here I just want to
point out that inequality is not the
result of animosity it is just the
result of the status quo its complacent
that causes it not evil just the
simplest path like I probably spent
enough money on like fancy dinners with
my wife this year to save the lives of
other people but I didn't do that I
bought fancy dinners with my wife
because that's what felt like the right
thing to do I that's just the normal
thing to do that's the status quo that
complacent the path of least resistance
that makes me presidents no I'm not evil
but I am complacent in that system just
like Katniss doesn't hate Effie I don't
hate myself for that but I do recognize
that because inequality is the path of
least resistance we have to have
structures to fight against it because
inequality isn't just bad for poor
people it's bad for the economy and it's
bad for people's happiness there is a
very strong correlation between the
Equality of a society and the happiness
of the people in that society not just
the happiness of the board people either
the rich people are happier too we have
to fight it we have to recalibrate for
equality and we can do that in a lot of
different ways we could do that by
helping people ourselves we can also do
it by making the government do it you
can also start on that path by signing
up the Harry Potter Alliance his odds in
our favor campaign a little bit of this
it's also why you should be thinking
about what you're gonna do for the
project for awesome this year and if you
cares about how to make a great project
for awesome video I just made a video
about that and uploaded it on the
project for awesome YouTube channel
which you can go check out you can learn
how to make good videos promoting great
charities John I'll see you on Tuesday
the project for awesome is in just 10
days which means that you need to buckle
down and figure out what that means